i knew this wasn't going to work so so
you're in a space the direction i'm
going is not going to work
do you know how mosquitoes work
mosquitoes are fun so they detect two
things they detect water vapor and
carbon dioxide
so mosquitoes will fly along in a
direction as long as the water vapor and
carbon dioxide are staying the same or
going up
but as soon as it starts to go down they
change direction in a random direction
right and within a couple of turns
they're aiming right for a mammal they
can they can fight
it's gotten colorful
so if you know you're going in the wrong
direction
a change in direction
can maybe is just as bad but there's
some chance it's good especially with
somewhat smart and you have some
experience
right so there was a whole bunch so even
a random move is better than no move if
the outcome is certain failure and so
that is some justification for taking a
risk
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to welcome
jim keller
to my youtube channel and podcast today
jim
is a microprocessor engineer
known for his work at digital equipment
amd
apple
tesla
and intel he was co-architect
for what were among the earliest of
64-bit microprocessors the ev5 and ev6
digital alpha processors designed in the
90s
in the later 90s he served as lead
architect for the amd k8 micro
architecture including the original
athlon 64 and was involved in designing
the athlon k7 and apple a4 through 7
processors
he was also the co-author of the
specifications for the x86 64
instruction set and hyper transport
interconnect
from 2012 to 2015
he returned to amd to work on the amd
k12 and zen micro architectures at tesla
he worked on automotive autopilot
hardware and software designing the
hardware 3 autopilot chip
he then served as senior vp of silicon
engineering
heading a team
of 10 000 people at intel
he is president presently
president and cto at tens torrent
building
ai computers
uh he's also my brother-in-law uh
and we've talked
a lot over the last 20 years he was a
friend of mine before he married my
sister and we've known each other for a
very long time since we both lived in
boston so i'm very happy to have you
to talk to you today jim i'm really
looking forward to it um
so thanks for agreeing to do this your
thing
so
let's walk through your career first it
it takes some unpacking your resume
takes some unpacking
to be comprehensible i would say so
let's start with digital equipment you
were working on very early stage
sophisticated microprocessors so
tell me about that
well it's
the the long story is you know i
graduated college as an electrical
engineer you know with a bachelor's and
i took a job in florida because i wanted
to live on the beach
and and it turned out to be a really
interesting job i was at harris and i
spent like two years working in labs
fixing up electrical equipment and doing
some networking stuff and some digital
design and at some point a friend told
me i should work at digital
so i read about digital and i literally
read the
computer architecture manual for the
back 780 on the plane on the way to the
interview
and then i interviewed them with a whole
bunch of questions because i just read
this this architecture spec which i
didn't know that much about to be honest
but i was kind of a wise ass as a kid
and um they hired me because they
thought it was funny
and uh so i got my you know
architectural education working on the
vax 8800
working for a guy named bob stewart
along with some other really great
architects
i spent about seven years in that group
you know learning to be a processor
architect and then i spent a little time
at digital research in california for
six months
and then went back and joined the hudson
team where they were building alpha
processors
and became call architect with pete
bannon on ev5 and then dirk with dirk
meyer and even sex
now those chips
15 years and
we worked on
i would say three very successful
shipping products and then a couple
other products that didn't get to market
so those chips from what i remember were
remarkably ahead of their time but that
didn't seem to save digital equipment
corporation
yeah is that fair to say that's
definitely fair to say the digital
literally made the world's fastest
computer
in the years they were going out of
business
and there was a there was a complicated
market dynamic digital was
very successful building mini computers
in the mini computer age which replaced
the mainframes to a large extent but
they missed the boat on the pc
revolution and would say workstations
and they had a big expensive computer
mindset
right when computer prices were
following much
so we were building really fast
processors for server and high-end
workstations
and the market had kind of moved on and
let's say a lot of crazy things were
going on inside the company at the time
yeah well we're going to return to the
topic of crazy things going on inside
computers but it's interesting to note
right there so that that that's a a
situation where a company has a great
product but doesn't know how to launch
it into the marketplace or is blinded by
its own preconceptions you can't even
see necessarily more than that gordon
bell was cto and he was a really
brilliant computer architect but he also
had really good let's say observational
skills
and
like during midway through the vax 8800
he decided the technology we were using
was too little too late and redirected
the program and it became a very
successful product because he knew what
was going on and he made decisions like
that
when he left i think digital became
an argument between business unit
managers not about technology
and alpha was a great technology but it
went into business units that were
aiming at high prices and high margins
not market penetration
and not basically keeping up with the
software revolution that was happening
so it was uh ken olsen was a great
manager but he wasn't a technical leader
and without gordon bell the company kind
of lost its way and when companies lose
their way they failed
and they felt fast too
you know they went from record profits
to
losing a billion a year and they kind of
rectified that for a little while and
then sales dropped off again and over
yeah well one of the things i've been
struck by watching your career and
talking to you over the years is exactly
that the rate at which a company that
appears dominant can disintegrate and
disappear is really quite some something
quite stunning i think
fortune 500 companies tend to last no
more than 30 years that it that that's
approximately the span and that's not
that's not a that's not a tremendously
long period of time so there's always
dominant companies and always a handful
of dominant companies but they the
company that's dominant tends to shift
quite quickly
so we should return to this a couple
times is the uh you know the classic s
curve in economics you start out low you
solve a problem you ramp up you plateau
and then you fail
and this dominates business and
dominates
humanity at some level and it you know
plays out over and over
now it sounds like you didn't have
and so how is it that you managed to do
this job you intimated when we were
talking that you weren't really trained
for it and
so you were trained as an engineer you
you had an is it a bachelor's degree in
in engineering
and
how prepared were you as a consequence
of your degree for any of the jobs that
you undertook
training is highly overrated
so
so a good engineering degree is math
physics basic understanding the science
and some smattering of communication
skills
you can probably do a great engineering
degree in two or three years
if you're dedicated to it you know the
the things that stretch my brains the
most when i went to college is with math
and mechanical engineering
um and penn state i went to penn state
and they used um
mechanical engineering and masses
through the weed out courses to find out
if you had
the chops or the gumption to get through
engineering so there was a fairly high
failure rate there but mechanical
engineering is a really interesting
discipline because you have to think
think about solving mass problems
spatially
like you know do things like how do you
calculate the force on a rotating
accelerating object
like it's somewhat complicated
and it makes you really think so you
have to learn to think and in
engineering school you never answer a
multiple choice question you learn stuff
and thermos and stuff but then you
calculate
and to understand what the result is and
the the problem sets are like little
design exercises
and so how much of it do you think
how much of it do you think is
pure screening let's say what wouldn't
be pure screening but fundamental
screening for
conscientiousness and iq and how much of
it is
learning to think
how much of the education process is
that like if you're going to hire an
engineer are you hiring fundamentally on
the basis of iq and you get smarter
people from the top schools or do you
think that the engineering training
actually does prepare people for a
technical career
um
well it depends on the engineer and
depends on the school and depends on
their approach
so my iq isn't super high compared to
really smart people i mean it's high
enough um
when i went to college it took me about
a year and a half
to learn how to think properly and i
found for me personally
i had to do the work on a regular basis
early i didn't study for finals i wasn't
the kind of person that could pick up a
book understand and get an aid the next
day and then forget about it i'm not i
can't do that so i had to learn how to
do the work go through the mechanisms
automatize some of the basics so i
didn't have to think about them so hard
but literally let my brain work on this
stuff
so then i could use them to go problem
solved
and especially in engineering there's
lots of different kinds of engineering
there's like highly technical stuff
where you turn the crank like a skilled
lawyer might
um but there's other stuff where you
have to be really creative if you have
an a problem that nobody solved before
and as an engineer you have a skill set
right but you have to apply it
creatively
and there's lots of high iq people who
aren't creative and there's you know low
iq people that are creative and you find
in a in a big engineering team there's a
real diversity of personality types
there's open-minded people conscientious
people
you know gregarious people and
it takes many different kinds of people
working together to do something
sophisticated
i'd say
you know like some of my senior classes
in engineering was just going a little
deeper on stuff i already knew
i could have left it after three years
and been just fine
but i do think the work i did
did help me you know be an engineer but
then
the problems i saw you know i worked on
after
i graduated college like in school
most of the problems you're given
there's a known answer because they're
in a book
you know and you're in a room with 20
people and they're doing the same stuff
um when you're an engineer working in
the company they never have two people
the same thing to do because that's a
waste of money
right and when you start engineering
you're given relatively small tasks by
you know your manager or supervisor
but as you go along at some point
um depends again on who you are you're
working on stuff that
you don't even know how to deal with you
know there's no answer in the book
so it's but it's not like physics right
like physicists are a funny bunch i
realized this the other day
that physicists
they're they're they're supposed to work
on stuff that's unsolved
whereas engineers you know
there's a big repertoire of engineering
and then it's reduction in practice and
then the world is complicated
so you you know go build a new bridge
that's never been built before it's not
like bridges are unsolved problem this
particular bridge hasn't been solved
before there may be unique challenges to
it
but it's not like physics where you're
looking for an unknown particle or
you know it's you know there's a pretty
big dividing line between
engineering and pure science engineers
typically working the names where
there's many many knowns and the
unknowns are
problems of the combination of you know
reality cons you know complexity
whereas physics of physics in principle
they're working on stuff that's
fundamentally on as soon as it's known
they have to move on because
because then it's engineering like the
physicists
you know translate the unknown into
engineering and engineering applies
known concepts to unknown problems
okay so you okay so now you you went
from digital to
amd
and you learned how to design
microprocessors so at amd you worked on
the k8 yeah and at that point amd was
losing ground to intel yes
and so how did you fix that
so basically dirk meyer and i were
co-architects of eb6 the third alpha
chip
he left about he left a digital kmd
about a year before i did he started the
k-7 project when i joined i started the
ka project
and then held and then worked with him
significantly on k7 as well
um
and how did we do it well
yeah so those were 64-bit chips that you
guys designed to compete with the the
fun the intel chips that have dominated
the comp the uh home computer market at
that point
well so there's a funny thing which is
like at some level building fast
computers isn't that far
right
so you have to have a goal
like so a lot of designers so they have
it they have a design
and then the easiest thing for the next
one is to go look at that design and
make it like 10 better 20 better
right but every one of those designs has
limitations built into it like like it's
sort of like if you have if you buy a
two bedroom house you can add one
bedroom
you can't add eight bedrooms like if you
want an eight-bedroom house you have to
build a different kind of house
right so
so every design build has kind of a
you know a range that it can play and
and you know you you build the first one
and you know you can make some
improvements but at some point the
improvements don't really help that much
right
so amd they had a design called k5 which
for complicated reasons didn't work out
that well and they lost ground to intel
before that they literally the 386 and
46 amd copied intel's designs they were
a clone manufacturer
the k5 was their first design and didn't
work out that good
and then they bought a company called
nextgen which had k6 which is an okay
design but it wasn't competitive against
intel and then k7
dirk was the chief architect of
and he designed a computer that was
competitive
in the head of intel
from and some of that came from our work
at digital on eb 5 and 86 turquoise as
well
and some of it was just saying in this
this day you know we have this many
transistors because you get more
transistors every generation so you can
basically imagine you're building a
house suddenly you have way more bricks
and way bigger steel beams
so your idea about what the build has to
scale with that
and then k7 was a 32-bit chip and then
k8 was a 64-bit chip
you know somewhat related to that as it
turned out
um but also it was built to be
bigger
and
what i did is
i wrote the performance model i came up
with the basic architecture and i
started organizing around building it
and while we were doing that we also
wrote the thing called hyper transport
spec
which became the basis of essentially
all modern server computers or what's
called two socket servers
we wrote that 98 in
2002 or 2022 they're still building them
that way and when you say you wrote it
what does that mean what what does the
process of writing that entail
what is it that you're writing and how
do you do that i'm dyslexic so i wrote
complete
you know
protocol spec about how two computer
chips talk to each other in 18 pages
right which is relatively terse
and there's a couple of pictures and you
know computer protocols are pretty
straightforward there's a command
there's the address you're talking to
there's the data you're moving there's
some protocol bits that tell you how to
exchange commands
right and then dirk dirk took the spec
and said you mind if i slash this out a
little bit and three days later he sent
me a 50 page version of it which
clarified all the little bullets
and then that specification we literally
used to build the interface between khs
right so
there's a couple levels designed
what sort of impact did that have what
sort of impact did that have on the on
the broader world what's the
significance it's very difficult for
non-engineers to understand
any of this
markets underground amd market share and
server went from 0 to 35
which was a huge impact for the business
and it became essentially the standard
because
apparently intel had a version of that
but it didn't go to market but after
opteron came out to market
intel built a similar version some more
protocol about how to how to connect a
small number of processors together with
that kind of interconnect
and then that
that
let's say design framework became
standard in the industry
so if you go into like a google data
center and you pull it out there'll be
two sockets with an interconnect between
the two of them and each socket will
have memory attached to it and they call
it the two p server or two processor
server
and it had a really big impact
we didn't do it because we thought it
was going to have a big impact we did it
because we thought it was a better way
to build computers
and at amd we were somewhat resource
constrained so we couldn't build a thing
that looked like a big ibm server so we
built was basically a small server with
the minimal amount of interconnect
between it so it was a little bit of
creativity by constraint
the steve jobs line and what function do
those servers have in again in the
broader world what are they doing now
for people
well it's basically the entire cloud
it's all google on the oh amazon or
facebook all microsoft reserve
but here's the interesting thing when we
built them the big server guys servers
used to be backlinks like this big with
multiple cpu slots
multiple memory cards multiple i o slots
and the server manufacturer thought the
server was oriented around the back
so ibm hp dell they all turned this down
but all the little startups at the time
like google
we're using pcs as low-cost servers
and we made this
basically you take a pc board instead of
putting one computer on you could put
two which radically saved the money
so when amd made those kinds of servers
it was a way lower entry point for
server class technology
and the little startups that depine used
it and then over 15 years disrupted all
the big server manufacturers
so it's you know it's one of those
i i i couldn't say we planned it like
there the constraints that we had a
target market we didn't know that it was
going to become
essentially how servers were built you
know for 20 odd years
but but it
happens after after amd you went to
apple
you worked on the a4 through seven
processors well i i was i worked at two
startups that did processors for
networking sidebite and ta semi and that
was probably about five or six years
and then i joined apple in 2008 so i
guess i was
no it must have been eight years i was
amd
98 1998 99 2000 and then i worked at
startups um
for about eight years and then i went to
apple
um
yeah and worked on mobile processors
and so tell tell me about those chips
and what you did at apple
i had some friends that were working in
apple and they wouldn't tell me what i
was going to work on so when i when i
interviewed there they said oh you
should just come here it'll be fun
and i didn't actually know what i was
going to work in
um they had a group called platform
architecture run by a guy named mike
colbert who was like the unofficial cpo
of apple he worked for steve jobs
and he had a group of architects that
you know looked at what apple was doing
and figured out what they should do next
and i worked on a macbook air
definition like i wrote the power
management's back and just did some
other architectural work
which ultimately was an nvidia chef
called mcp89
and then i was one of the chief
architects of
you know four generations of socs what's
called a four eight five eight six a7
and we did a lot of stuff there because
but the division was
you know socs are what yeah system on a
chip
oh yes you pack a computer into a phone
you have a piece of silicon about that
big
and all the components the cpu the gpus
i o are all on the same chip and when
they first started building phone ships
they were considered to be very slow
low cost
you know very integrated chips
and we thought
if you looked ahead
because technology shrinks about every
two years
in about six or eight years we'd have
enough transistors on a phone chip that
would be more powerful than the pc at
the time
so we started architecting
computers interconnects and other
functions so that when we had enough
transistors
we could literally have you know a
high-end desktop on a phone
and apple is uh apple's dna
is you create the product that kills
your your current product
so you create the product that that
killed so every company has a great
product and they worry about competitors
coming in to kill it and apple wanted to
be the first to kill their own products
so steve jobs thought phones and tablets
would replace pcs
and he wanted to be the first to do it
he didn't want somebody else to do it to
him and did you know jobs
no
i've seen him a couple times i said hi
to him twice
i felt like i knew him pretty well
everybody at apple did like when steve
wanted something done everybody knew the
next day
um my boss mike talked to him every
single day multiple times sometimes
it's a joke like we'd walk in mike's
office and he'd be holding the phone out
like this
he goes steve he's pissed
we're like yes
so what but mike could translate what
steve wanted into engineering stuff and
he
trusted mike a lot
and like he could translate division
into engineering
and steve steve's judgment on stuff like
this is spectacular so and
did you have any sense do you have any
sense of why that is i mean jobs was
famously obviously originated apple and
then was famously brought back in to
save them when they when they were in
danger of extinction and then in fact
did seem to save them and you never know
when you hear about these things from
the outside how much of that is sort of
a mythology mythologization of a person
and how much of it is
you know this person was really singular
and
so unique
singular and unique i mean your
psychological parlance as we talked
about he would be considered
high in openness and disagreeableness
right and i think negative emotionality
like he was a very difficult person
but the solution to
you know things could go really bad
and being disagreeable was i'm gonna
make it as great as possible
and he was willing to take the risk for
that
you know his public persona was very
well practiced
mike used to say the worst the practice
for the you know apple keynotes
uh the better they would go off
like like he was throwing iphones you
know at one of the iphone
you know pre-launch practices because
nothing was right but then when he
showed up and you know his persona of uh
you know technical explainer let's say
you know that was very real that's what
he wanted to portray and he believed
every single bit of it you could tell
so you know any engineers that when i
joined apple
i watched some of his early keynotes
when he came back to apple and changed
the max
you know it's inspiring
but you know it's also super tough right
because he went into a company that was
very dysfunctional had a whole bunch of
you know engineering groups doing
basically random stuff
let's say senior managers who felt like
they owned their product lines and knew
what they were doing
and you know steve wanted him to do what
he wanted them to do and they didn't
want to do it i'm pretty sure he cleaned
house streets early
and uh he famously reduced the product
line from you know who knows how many
products like four
you know it was consumer
professional
so do you think it was that
disagreeableness i mean we hear all the
time now in the modern world about the
necessity for empathy and so forth and
um that's the agreeableness dimension
and you're making the claim that jobs
was low in agreeableness and that he was
able to kill off malfunctioning projects
and
um that's not exactly a nice thing to do
so imagine you go to a room full of
people dedicated their life in the last
five years of their work
five years of their careers building
products that you can't sell
and you say we have to do something
completely different and everybody's you
know every day as an engineer you're
working something you
embrace it you love it care about it
like engineers are very emotional people
somewhere in their pointy little souls
right
so but so but if it's not working out
for whatever reason you have to do
something different
and if you listen to everybody you'll
never change anything
right it's difficult to get people
reoriented
now another line you gave me i don't
know where it came from is you run
fastest when you're running towards
something
and away from something
yeah that was from animal experimental
literature if you if you threaten a rat
and re and offered a reward
simultaneously it will run faster
towards the reward than if you just
reward it because you get all your
motivational systems on board that way
yeah yeah
so steve was very good at division
we are going to build this beautiful
computer
right
and you better god damn build it now or
you're going to die so that was his okay
so the openness
so that's the creativity dimension that
gives him the vision he's extroverted
can he communicate enthusiastically
she can certainly put on the actor i
have no idea who's an expert or not i
never saw them
be extroverted in any natural setting i
just you know i've seen him walk around
like i said i used to see him in the
cafeteria he was he was visible on the
apple campus even until his last days he
didn't like to be bothered like he
didn't go up to say to steve and say hey
steve how's it going
right well that would be reflective of
basic disagreeableness too right um you
know it's hard with it's hard sometimes
people can communicate very effectively
communicate a vision because they are
high in openness extroverted people are
enthusiastic and assertive so they tend
to be verbally dominant and can inspire
people because they generate a lot of
positive emotion but that can be
mimicked by openness
so yeah so you have to remember like
steve was part of pixar
and very much part of hollywood and you
know creating movies and creating
personas and characters and archetypes
though he was super well grounded in how
that stuff works and what works and
doesn't work about it
right and he had an unerring eye for for
for beauty
and elegance and remarked about it and
he would fight for that and that's hard
it's very hard to fight for beauty and
elegance and i suspect it's particularly
hard perhaps maybe i'm wrong about this
but i would think that would be a hard
sell to to at least a subset of
engineers
yeah so another addition to explain to
uh
my boss at tesla was i worked both for
elon and for a guy named doug field
and doug said there's this no
there's this productivity graph versus
order so that the origin is zero
productivity and chaos
right
and then as you add order to your design
methods your productivity will go up
and what happens with engineers is they
they understand as they get better
processes they get better trained they
get better
at working together every single thing
that makes the whole organization more
orderly improves productivity
unfortunately that peaks at some point
and then
too much order productivity goes down
and so then the yeah you know as i say
any idiot can see you should be at the
peak note enough order to really be
effective but not so much ordering grind
to a halt
but why can't you stay there
and the reason is is once order takes
over the organization it's unstoppable
right it feels good you get even better
at doing what you're doing you get even
more organized you micromanage your time
even better you close out all the
creativity you're not open to change
a whole bunch of bad things happen you
shut out the disorderly people who
actually know how to make a change and
do something creative
and the organization dies
so successful i think that jobs was
conscientious as well
you know like was he in early working
18-hour days was i know he was up in the
middle of the night because he called
michael on that stuff well the point is
both steve and elon were counter forces
to order
right you have to be really strong to
avoid your organization getting captured
by order
well order also has its
remarkable error of moral virtue right
because it's yeah yeah it's pure and
it's efficient it feels good
you know
but it's you know it's like it's like
alcohol the first drink feels right the
second feels okay the third one not that
good
but you know
you keep remembering what the first one
did so you drink too much
right it's a you know there's lots and
lots of processes you know
where
some is good too much is bad but the
counter force the more is weak
and and that's the thing that you know
so steve was interesting because he was
simultaneously super creative
and had visions which could inspire
people but he also
prevented the company from being over
organized
and preventing him from doing what he
was doing and that's hard because people
like i said they get committed to what
they're doing
yeah well
it's an open question like imagine that
the creative process has a productive
component and then a culling component
and
the productive component looks like it's
associated with openness but
what the culling component is is open to
question and it does seem to me that at
least upon occasion it's it's low
agreeableness it's the ability to say no
we're going to dispense with that and
and
and to not let anything stand in the in
the face of that decision which would
also include
often
human compassion
yeah and people have different
approaches to it like like jobs would
call things so they weren't beautiful or
they weren't great
you know elon musk was famous for
getting the first principles and really
understanding it fundamentally and
culling from like a standpoint of
knowledge
um
yeah and you you've asked me like what
makes a an engineer great
like so you have to have the will to
creativity
like now there's lots of engineering
jobs that aren't creative like you need
a skill set you can exercise the skill
set
but if you're going to build new things
you need to be creative but you also
have to have a filter good enough to
figure out what's actually good and bad
like i know a lot of really creative
engineers and they find a new thing
excited and go down the rabbit hole on
it and they you know they can work on it
for six months and nothing to show for
it so you have to have that
conscientiousness i don't know if it's
conscientious disagreeableness you know
that that taste on how well the
conscientiousness would keep you working
in the direction that you've chosen
and and doing that
diligently and orderly the the low
agreeableness well that's that's the
open question because agreeableness is
such a
complicated dimension there's obvious
disadvantages and advantages at every
point on the distribution i mean
disagreeable people are often harder to
work with because they don't care much
about your feelings but one thing i've
noted about working with disagreeable
people is you always know what they're
thinking and if you want someone to tell
you what's stupid and wrong they're
perfectly willing to do that
yeah you saw i used to watch i used to
wonder so dirk meyer was a disagreeable
manager but he could tell you what was
wrong with what you were doing in the
way you would go okay
like he was very unemotional about it
like he goes jim i really like this and
this but this isn't working for
like what are we going to do about it
and and you just would just be our shot
as a matter of fact
um
i would say when i was younger
i was a lot less disagreeable you know
i'm fairly open
minded and you know i like to create new
stuff kind of stuff things but then i
saw enough things fail over the years
because we didn't make that you know
let's say the hard choices about
something
and then
you know you hate to work on something
for two years and have it go away
because at some point you realize you're
doing a couple wrong things
and you didn't do something about it
when you could
and so as a you know as a manager and a
senior leader
i'm somewhat famously disagreeable
and part of it's an act to get people to
move and part of its
you know my beliefs that i can't have
people dedicate themselves to doing bad
things
for very long because it'll
it'll bite us yeah well
we've talked a little bit about this too
about the moral dilemma between
agreeableness and conscientiousness
they're both
virtues agreeableness seems to me to
govern short-term intimate relationships
like that between a mother and a child
and it involves very careful attention
to the emotional
reactions of another person
and and and the optimization of those in
the short term but conscientiousness
looks like a longer term virtue and and
they come into conflict at some points
because sometimes because
in the midterm
yes
right yeah that's you know could just be
you know how our brains see the future
but
it's like you know if you're managing
the group and you have to fire somebody
it's hard right but do you want to fire
five people now or everybody later like
well like once you've internalized that
and taken responsibility for that
decision then making
you know management leadership position
choices
is always hard but it's so much better
to make them
and then then succeed than it is to fail
because you couldn't make the hard calls
yeah well it isn't obvious at all who's
who's got the upper hand you know
someone who fires early
out of necessity but is accurate and
looking carefully or someone who
you know is willing to let people
just drag on i'll give you i'll give you
two counter examples of that so jack
walsh in this book
straight from the gut a weird thing he
said you know once you have a doubt on
somebody you never act fast enough
which you know it took me years to
really believe that
and then the other weird one is
people say i have this organization of
100 people and there's five
five people aren't working out but i'm
not sure who they are
so i'm going to be really careful
because i don't want to accidentally
fire a good person
right that makes sense right you got
five bad people you know maybe you
figure out who two or three of them are
but there's this other group of five or
ten you're not sure which ones are the
wrong ones
here's the sad truth there's a lot of
people in the world
you're better firing too many than too
few
and how did you come to terms with that
emotionally i mean look we have a mutual
friend who fires people with quite great
regularity and i've talked to him and he
scores very high in disagreeableness and
i talked to him about firing which he's
done a lot of and he was actually quite
positive about it he said i don't fire
anyone who i don't think is causing more
trouble than preventing and so by firing
the person that i'm firing i'm actually
doing a very large number of people
including potentially that person a
favor it didn't bother him but he was
temperamentally wired that way i would
say but
i i would say
you know digital equipment went bankrupt
because they had bad people who didn't
fire i've seen many groups fail because
they couldn't clean the house
right and
the impact on you know the greater good
equation is super easy you want to save
90 people or you know lose a hundred
so
so that's true
the the thing that took me a while to
realize that
um
the world needs shaking up all over the
place and individuals do right
a lot of people who are not doing too
good they they need a wake-up call you
give them a bad review and they kind of
shrug they're like what are you gonna do
about it you know it's like a spoiled
kid nothing right
but when they actually get fired they
really have to do some soul
and then the fact that if you're doing
something good there's always a queue
outside the door more people
now here's another way to think about
take a group of 100 people and rank them
from top to bottom
human beings by the way are really good
at this
you have four managers in the group
except for the manager's individual
friends they'll tend to rank 100 people
the same way i've done this experiment
many times but we're really good at
ranking and there's a little bit of what
are you ranking for you're ranking for
creativity productivity
conscientiousness
but if you set the criteria right people
rank pretty well
if you have a 100 people in your group
and there's 50 people outside
the distribution of those 50 people is
around the average
of the team
right so there's this idea that you fire
the bottom 10 percent of its theme
because the random people you hired will
be better on average than the bottom 10
percent of your team
right it's just math unfriendly
statistics right but yes i get the
argument right the problem is that every
company that does that
first it gets game because managers hire
bottom 10 percenters so when they get
the fire the 10 they don't have to fire
their friends
right and it also really is hard on
morale
like people
people bond and there may be people in
the bottom 10 of your group that are the
social glue of the organization so you
may be inadvertently
taking out the stuff that makes the team
work right well that's a measurement
error too right it means that your
criteria for competence aren't broad
enough yeah
that's tough good point maybe you're
ranking a little wrong but uh impact on
morale is high teams
generally speaking uh rory reed was ceo
of amd when i joined
and we had a big layoff which we had to
do because we were running out of money
we're broke and uh
when we all the dust settled we we
landed on just
the right amount of people for the money
we had and he basically registered
actually said
he said guys
teams have to grow
when you cut you always cut further and
then you
grow people aren't happy unless they're
growing
right it's like when you prune bushes
and stuff you don't prune the bush to
where you want the bush you prune the
bush past that point so it grows out and
looks nice
right things have to grow it's really uh
an amazing dynamic
well yeah well and it's never it's never
clear how much death there is involved
in growth and the pruning analogy is
exactly that
and this is harsh stuff obviously but
yeah you look like one collapse or
another it's right that's the thing it's
not harsh
because it's beautiful when you prune
your bush and growth back beautifully
it's great when you rebuild an
organization
that's really strong and powerful
because you made the right calls right
like like this isn't just negative stuff
it's
hard stuff to do that creates something
really great
like you know when i joined amd and what
was it 2013 or something
like they had two product lines you know
bulldozer and jaguar and they're both
failing
and i had i i can't i cancelled both
products
like
okay and so what was the human cost of
that i would say both to you and and
also to the people that were involved
well i did i did the math on it it's
like you know we needed to be building
eight billion bedroom houses and we're
trying to add six bedrooms to a two
bedroom house in one case it was never
gonna work
yeah so you saw that as doomed to
failure and the other one was
structurally screwed up it seemed to be
the right ballpark for the performance
we should get but the way it was
engineered and built
was sort of like you know you let the
plumber do the architecting and the
house looks like
and um it was it was difficult you know
for complicated reasons technical
reasons there was no path out of where
they were
and when i realized i had to cancel them
um yeah it was sleepless nights here we
are we had we had revenue on that we had
people committed to it people really
liked it when i canceled it um
especially on the jaguar team a
significant number of people quit
because they were angry about it um
there were some pretty big new
organizations there was some management
we had to let go
the best architect at the time well one
of the best architects at amd was he
really was my way or the highway and he
was you know he he could not communicate
what he was doing so i let him go
um which is a strange thing to do
so if he ranked the organization you
were ranked near the top and i let one
of those guys go because he was
ineffective working with the team
and how did you justify that to yourself
and
how how did you check yourself against
stupidity and ignorance and you know
self-interest and how did you know that
what you were doing was right
well i'm a little lower in
conscientiousness than i should be for a
senior later first of all
so
i knew this wasn't going to work so so
you're in a space the direction i'm
going is not going to work
do you know how mosquitoes work
mosquitoes are fun
so they detect two things they detect
water vapor and carbon dioxide
so mosquitoes will fly along in a
direction as long as the water vapor and
carbon dioxide are staying the same or
going up
but as soon as it starts to go down they
change direction in the random direction
right and within a couple of turns
they're aiming right for a mammal they
can they can bite it's gotten colorful
so if you know you're going in the wrong
direction
a change in direction can maybe is just
as bad but there's some chance it's good
especially if you're somewhat smart and
you have some experience
right so there was a whole bunch so even
a random move is better than no move if
the outcome is is certain failure and so
that is some justification for taking a
risk now there's an incident number of
failed directions but
you're somewhat informed right and then
the other problem is like when you build
a house it has a foundation once the
foundation is built
it's very difficult to change the top of
the house a lot
like you have foundation for a two-story
house
it's hard to make it into an eight-story
so when we cancel those projects we
consciously reset
some design methodologies you know some
team organizations and leadership some
let's say
you know
we we we said we're going to have the
best in class
leadership design methodology
and some of the architectural tools
we're just going to we're going to take
those as givens now that now that the
land has been cleared we had the
opportunity to go back and do that
and it was interesting and uh in the
design teams it turns out there was some
very good pieces
you know in the two processors they had
but they weren't working together
organically like they should and then
say the framework of the design wasn't
big enough
and then the tools over the years have
evolved into lots of little local
improvements but it wasn't really the
right tool set
now amd leapt forward when you did this
and they were the only competitor to
intel in a realistic sense and so this
these actions on your part were part of
what made that company thrive and kept
competition within the microprocessor
world so these didn't have these
decisions didn't have trivial outcomes
oh no it had really great outcomes
and and there was
the really cool thing was you know when
we did that we didn't really bring in
outsiders like that zen design was
entirely
based on people who worked at amd at the
time
right so what we needed was
to clear the plate a little bit
to re-establish some you know first
principles
about how we were doing things to have a
better goal
um there was a little bit of head
knocking on getting like the
methodologies straightened out
you know i was uh let's say fairly
disagreeable about how we were going to
get through that because people kept
saying oh it's too hard to do this well
is it any good no
well if it's no good it doesn't matter
how hard it is
you have to do it right if you're going
to drown
you don't go well a mile is too far to
swim so i'm just not going to swim
you're going to drown right if you're a
mile offshore and you're drowning
swimming a mile is the requirement right
and i've explained that like a million
different ways
when something is pretty good you know
the the world's you don't divide it into
three things things are good so you're
happy and things are bad you fix it
and then there's the middle ground where
it's it's not great but it's not killing
those are the ones where human beings
have a really hard time improving
right so by canceling the projects and
declaring everything bad
everything could be improved
all right
what was it what bugged me about it it
was like jim this wasn't that bad well
was it great was it going to win no all
right it's bad i defined everything
that's not great back if i moved you
know a little dis on the continuum
everything five percent or more away
from gray is bad period
and how did you like how did you
decide that was a good criteria
why did you decide that was a good
criteria that all the time we were
competing with intel and on a whole
bunch of metrics
like like literally their cpu had twice
the frequency twice the performance per
clock a whole bunch of metrics were so
good
so we plotted them all
like you know i had a whole bunch of
data on this stuff but also as a mindset
like if it wasn't best in class like a
computer has a whole bunch of things in
it there's something called a branch
predictor which predicts which way
branches are going theirs was way better
than ours we could measure
so we did
there's a thing called you know memory
system their memory system was way
better it was twice as fast
so it's like well we need to be within
10 of them on everything or we're going
to get our assets kicked
and it'll be really nice if we're better
on some things
so we measured all their stuff
like if you're going to compete you know
like in basketball you don't just
players you know play yourself
you know you try to see what the other
teams are doing what are they good at
what are they bad at you know every
every coach is great at doing analysis
of all the competition
and then then you know you win two ways
you meet the competition with what
they're good at and then you have some
secret plays that you're better off than
surprising
given recent scotus wins it feels like
the pendulum may be swinging back to a
time when the nuclear family was
situated at the center of american life
where real conversation learning and
growth began at home president ronald
reagan said in his farewell address that
all great change in america begins
around the dinner table well all great
meals in america begin with good
ranchers good ranchers cares deeply
about providing families with steakhouse
quality beef chicken and seafood meat at
a reasonable price their mission is to
bring people to the table making those
shared moments with your loved ones easy
accessible and delicious good rancher
ships 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the u.s right to your door
plus when you subscribe your price is
locked in for the life of your
subscription great food creates great
conversation and great conversation
makes great change so start bringing
people back to the table with high
quality american meat go to
goodranchers.com peterson to get 30 off
your first order plus free shipping
that's goodranchers.com
peterson
so you went from you went from amd to
tesla
so and we talked a little bit about elon
musk i want to ask you about him and
your experiences at tesla um but also
and what you did there
sure so let's talk about elon musk to
begin with sure
well he's a pretty public guy so i i
don't know that i can add that much
um
well kind of what you said about steve
jobs was it true yeah it's mostly true
like like elon's the real deal
he's like he's a really good engineer
he has his belief that he can learn
deeply about anything fast and he's
practicing he does it i've seen him do
it
like he gets into lots of details
now he has done five impossible things
yeah yeah it's it's pretty it's pretty
respectable
and he likes the details and he has a
good eye for it um
usually before
before tesla when you do a technical
presentation usually dumb you have some
kind of methodology for presenting the
problem to an executive what's the
problem what's you know the background
of that
elon is solution person
like if i don't like your solution i
don't care about the stupid problem and
your data you know just forget it no
what's the solution there's a solution
great great
then everything else is back up you know
what's the data behind that thing oh
we've got the data what was the problem
like how did you figure this out oh
here's the original problem we found
like he likes you know he has a reverse
order for most people most people tell
you historians problem
now here's how we figured it out here's
the background data here's how we built
the solution here's the solution here's
the next steps like that's a typical
technical presentation it's not a bad
idea elon hated it
like stop with the what's the
goddamn solution
can you give me an example of that
um
we had a problem with low resolution
camera images
right and we were trying to improve like
how the computer perceived roads and
like low-light conditions
so we started with
well here's the resolution of the camera
here's the light sensitivity here's the
images we're getting and he was like
what the
you have a solution
well yeah we do we have the software
that does this well
page 12 why is it on page 12.
page one have been a really good place
here's the old image here's the new
image here's how we did it
right that's what he wanted now partly
it's high back so did that would would i
so what i'm wondering is what was
effective about that was it that there
was an ethos then that the most
important thing that you had to bring
forward wasn't a problem but it was a
solution and so that people were
striving constantly to generate and
communicate solutions which seems like a
good strategy well no i think
he's worried so engineer sees a problem
and they start investigating it and then
as you're investigating you get develop
understanding and you're understanding
the problem as a good
like you would think that right
you know you think that lots of people
think that elon doesn't think that
elon wants a solution
right and if you're falling in love with
your understanding and you're falling in
love with your little details well that
also feels like work you know you
mentioned earlier that just because it's
hard doesn't mean it's useful right and
and both focus
you are focused like crazy on the
solution
the best way to do that so then you have
two states right if there's a problem
there's two states you have a solution
and you don't have a solution
if you have a solution that's on page
one
we're all happy yeah well i've seen in
that you don't have a solution why the
hell are you talking to me why aren't
you finding the damn solution yeah yeah
i've seen in the software projects other
projects that i've been involved in too
that
focusing on a solution i think this is
along the same lines as what you're
discussing is well then you get a you
get to product a lot faster
it's like this thing has to exist and
work maybe it won't solve and the
problem with the problem is that you can
indefinitely investigate the problem and
expand it and also that that feels like
work but it's not saleable yeah
yeah it it puts in the forefront of your
mind you know that constant you know you
need to be creative pursuing the problem
but also make sure you're really on
track of the solution and you're just
not falling in love with the problem
people call it admiring the problem some
engineers are great at admiring problems
like i've worked lots of people to come
in with a 12-page presentation and when
i'm done i'm like
did you guys just
give me a whole bunch more data on the
problem you said yeah we're really
getting to the bottom of it it's like no
you're not you're not getting anywhere
well the bottom of a problem is a
solution
because why would you just investigate
the problem right i mean that your
destination no they just keep getting
deeper and deeper into problem
admiration and
and nothing happens
okay
three quarters of engineers would be
perfectly happy to do that their whole
life
because
so you explain this to me complex
mastery behavior
right so humans are very you know we
like to learn
right we don't like to do dumb
repetitive things
right but we like to do things that are
complicated that we've mastered that
take skill and you know you know insight
but
you can have complex mastery behavior
just analyzing problems right definitely
right and there's careers for that some
people find they're really good at it
they're a problem they're analysts they
generate lots of data
but if you're in charge of solving
problems
you know that that
that period needs to be
focused short and concise and you need
to move on to solutions
right i think that's probably why i'm
not so temperamentally fond of activists
are they problem admirers
well that's what it looks like to me
it's like well that's a this is one of
the reasons i admire elon musk it's like
well you're comparing you're concerned
about the environment well why don't you
build an electric car then
right
well so a large number of people this is
the my favorite thing i learned it was
working with mechanical engineers with
tesla they think the world's made out of
silly putty
right they used to design when we were
building model three they designed the
part and joke about how they're gonna
make it are they gonna you know see in
cnc it like mill it or they can
injection mold it 3d print it stamp it
make it with a hammer you know cut it
out scissors
you know carve it out of a block
made this cool machine that could carve
3d models out of clay
like it was was funny like so they they
could design things in their heads and
on computers and then go build any damn
thing they want
if you ever look at them
complicated mechanical assembly would be
some screwed aluminum thing it would be
built somewhere and then drilled and
there's screws going through it maybe
some little tabs sticking off of it that
holds another thing
like they can make stuff right they
think they think they can make anything
right and there's a whole bunch of
people in the world that don't think
they can make him they don't they think
the world is what it is
i i had a friend he had a he had a
rattle on his dashboard
and he didn't know what to do about it
and i was asking him where the rattle
was and you know
and i was thinking that i was talking to
him about like how the dashboard is made
and he goes
oh i get it you think the dashboard's
made of a whole bunch of parts that are
put together somewhere i thought the
dashboard was just the dashboard
like he could he didn't conceptualize it
as there's his outer piece and there's
inner brackets and there's radio and
there's just these things
because mentally i can't help but see
the whole thing in 3d
and then i'm wondering which which piece
is loose and where it is
right and then how to fix it like
like i'm i'm not mechanical engineering
creative but
but i'm visual like that like
and and for people who get stuck on
activism as problem description they
don't think the world can change
which at some level makes sense you know
for human evolution
like you know it was pretty much the
same for a million years like it's weird
how good we are at change um
and my my best theory on it is from zero
to 20. like your brain is going through
radical change because you're going from
you know silly putty and not knowing
much to being pretty smart so you have
to change and adapt really fast and then
humans
are adapted to deal with each other and
the humans are fairly crafty
you know you have to deal with that but
but you know the lifestyle of most
people from you know
you know say 30 deaths it's fairly
static
and you know so we have this funny
capacity
for
learning rapidly exponentially
and then dealing with slowly changing
environments but we're not naturally
adopted the rapids
in the modern world is
well especially in engineering is rapid
change
and um
it was just so funny like
you never knew what they were up to like
one day
like they were working on the interior
for the car and they made this crazy
looking model which kind of looked like
a car but it turned out it was a thing
you could move around and have the
attachment points for all the interior
parts
so you could basically it looked like a
weird skeleton
but it had the attachment points that
you could adjust and you could build all
the interior parts and put a tesla
interior together right in the middle of
the
where the engineering desks were it was
really cool
um and let them go build it and think
about it and then within the cad model
and the computer you could see it but
you didn't always work out in real life
like we have a scale problem when you
look at something that's small even if
you scale it up perfectly when it's big
sometimes that's just what you thought
and sometimes it doesn't work
and so you know you want to do you know
computers like to change things fast
but like real scale models that you sit
in and live it and you know get a human
experience for it
and it was really fun for them to just
show up and be like holy cats if i did a
similar thing we took all the electrical
subsystems and motors and laid them out
on two tables
two big tables covered with all the
electrical parts of a model three
we stared at it and once you see them
all together it's crystal clear that
could be a lot better
because you know there's your three
motors that look almost the same why
isn't that one motor there's these two
parts that are completely separate
separate some release assemblies but if
you build it together you could have one
thing do both things really much more
naturally a lighter lighter weight right
and by laying that all out in front of
you you didn't have to do the mental
work of representing that you could do
the mental work of
seeing how all the parts interconnected
and what might be
yeah
yeah doug clark is an architect i worked
with when i was a kid at digital called
it the intraocular traumatic test
when you look at it
does it bug you
and a lot of things when you really lay
them out like that you go oh we're not
doing this right
and uh and elon liked that kind of stuff
like you know you're almost afraid to
show them like when you laid it all out
you looked at and go this is crazy so it
was like do we show me alone or not
because you'll look at it i think this
is crazy like you built this car who did
this
gave us so i wanted to talk to you too
i want to talk to you like i'm someone
very stupid and and in this particular
regard i am
um
i really don't understand how
computation works
and you're a microprocessor architect
and you build computers and so i'm and i
listened to a discussion you had earlier
earlier this month um and there was a
lot of it i couldn't follow i thought it
might be helpful and interesting
for you just to walk through for me and
for my audience how a computer actually
works what it does and how you build it
and and then what it would be like to to
design and to architect uh a
microprocessor yeah
well
it's it's somewhat hard to describe but
there's a couple simple things so let's
start with the easiest thing
the computers have three components
really
memory
programs
and input and output
right those are the three basic things
we always build
right so memory is like the dram or the
disk drive a place where you store data
and it's just stored and it have
different representations we currently
use ones and zeros
like so you can take any
any any
bit of information than described as a
sequence of ones and zeros and it's
stored in silicon
in either static and dynamic memories or
on disk drives which you know there's a
couple technologies for that
memory make sense to you a place to
store information well it does although
i have some difficulty in understanding
exactly how the transformation is
undertaken to represent things in zeros
and ones i mean
i'll give i'll give you a simple example
so if you shine a light
on a photo of photo detective
right so the light comes in
and it's a it's a stream of photons
right and the photo detector counts the
photons
literally
so every photon that hits it or a couple
photons hit it they cause some electric
charge to move and that causes the
circuit to wake up and say i saw some
photons
so say you're trying to evaluate how
strong that light is
so it can be anywhere from nothing to
super intense
right and then you might say
well let's let's put that in a range of
numbers from zero to a thousand
right so and and then you're trying to
lay on it and so you count the photons
for say you know microseconds
and then you translate how many photons
you counted into the number
right so
and so just imagine as as the light
varies up and down the count the number
coming out of your photo detector is
varying between zero and a thousand
right and and we use base 10
but you can translate that to binary
which is base two
and now you have ones and zeros you
you've basically now translated
a light ray optical information
to account
so virtually everything can be
represented by account apparently
so just think of your computer it has a
camera which is essentially doing just
that
when you get different colors but first
you go through color filters so you have
a green filter and a red filter and a
blue filter that's enough to represent
the color spectrum and then you have a
little little photon counter underneath
that
and it counts for a little while and
then you ship out the number and you
reset it and count again so the light
varies you're getting that there's a
pretty big grid like a modern camera's
12 million
you know photo detectors in it
actually 36 million because it's got
different colors but
well depends on how they build it
like they might have different pixels be
different colors and interpolate the
colors like a keyboard is really simple
so the fundamental issue to begin with
is that you reduce everything to account
and then you you represent that count in
in base two base two it's base two right
zero and one
and you can do the same thing with sound
you can have a sound detector that
basically counts you know intensity of
sound waves and the keyboard well you
have a little grid of keys when you push
a key it sends what which key was that
that was key number 27 so now you can
it's either on or off on or off you know
so d might be count number 26 and f is
27 and g is 28.
so everything gets encoded into a number
and then computer is like binary numbers
you know for for technical reasons but
that's not a big deal so so memory so
input and output is the first thing you
see so the computer's built around the
memory so the input and output system so
the inputs all your photo detectors
sound detectors keyboard detectors
and there's amazing numbers of sensors
these days you can detect gravitational
waves maybe
you can detect you know photons you can
detect electrical waves sound waves
you can take temperature you know it's
very varied you turn all that stuff into
a number and then your input device
writes that into memory
and memory stores information you know
memory used to be small and expensive
and now it's big and cheap but
it's still just memories
and nothing happens to it in the memory
it just gets stored
if you look inside the computer it's a
big memory and it's full of numbers
now
the person who's writing the program you
know is telling like the input output
like here comes the input video stream
put the put the video stream address 1
million so all the memory is addressed
and the address typically starts at zero
and modern computer goes up to billions
okay so walk through that again the
addressing so what what what's exactly
the function of that well you want to
know where the memory is
okay right you need to okay fine yeah so
so basically your phone probably i don't
know has eight or sixteen gigabytes of
memory in it yeah maybe yeah four or
eight i don't know
so billion you know eight billion
bytes of information in there
so
and when you're designing your programs
and kind of lay out well here's our the
operating system is going here's what
the input output buffers are here's
memory we're going to use to run some
program
so and all that's addressed
so you can think of the addresses it's
just like a post office right
so you know every every house has a
postal address
you know it's a street address and then
your house address and so you can find
every person
and the address corresponds to the
physical location in some sense to the
physical location of the of the and how
are the zero and ones represented in the
memory
it's uh literally a voltage that's
either high or low and zero is using
ground which is zero volts
and modern you know dram cells probably
stored at 1.1 volts
and you know in a dram cell it's a
capacitor that's holding electrons
so basically when you store the cell and
either you drain all the electrons out
so it's zero volts or you put a bunch of
electrons in so that it holds a one volt
so it's literally a number of electrons
in there there's a couple ways to make
memory cells there's another way which
is called a bistable element where you
have what's called cross-couple
inverters but that's
too complicated to explain
and then the the memories are usually
built in rays so there's an x y
so you take the number and you say i'll
take the bottom half of the number and
figure out which row it's in and the top
has a number of which column it's in
and where the column and the row overlap
then i'll write my new data of a one and
zero in that spot
it's literally that simple
so if you look at a memory chip you'll
see this array of bits
with little
blocks on on two edges
usually you know one side's the row one
side's the column and then the bottom is
what they call the sentence when you
read it back out again
so so memory processes you activate the
wrong column to a spot which gives you
the address of that bit
and then you drive the bid in and charge
up or discharge that cell
and then it holds them
and it's super simple you can build a
memory with a pegboard you could build a
memory people literally did
you know way back when there was
something called clear memory
where they had essentially the xy grid
and at each little place there was a
little magnetic
bead
which when you put the currency you
could you put the current in the same
direction you could make it be north to
south and the opposite direction south
and north so the you know magnet you
basically re-magnetize the little beads
so there's lots of ways to make memory
but currently the really dense memories
are called dynamic memories where you
literally put charge in there
and then there's fun stuff that happens
like flash cells the cells got so small
that the electrons you know from the
quantum effects tunnel out occasionally
so you put
about where the electron actually is yes
and sometimes it could literally jump
out of the cell once it jumps out and it
doesn't come back
so
so they got down to like 25 electrons in
the cell and they would wander off over
a couple hours you have to refresh them
so periodically you go back and you read
the data before too much of its escape
and you write it back in
you know so it's called refreshing the
memory
but drams hold more charge than that and
then the flash guys figure out how to
stack the cell so
modern flash chips there's an xy grid
but there's also a c dimension
they're like 256 layers thick now
so it's like a three dimensional memory
but the simple thing still is it's a
linear
range of addresses where you put some
data okay so that's memory so the next
component
is programs
this is the compute part
so it took a simple program simple
program is
a equal b plus c
right so
the data at address a
so so when you write the program you
tend to use what you call variable names
a b and c
but there's a tool called compiler which
will sign aids and say address 100 and b
the address 101 and see the address 102
right
and then the pro
the computer when it's running
says do what i told you to do so you see
this this program a equal b plus c
so you get
b
you get c
you add them together you put it in a
and typically what happens is you you
have a what's called a local memory or a
registered file so you get the data from
memory into the register file you do
whatever operation you're supposed we're
told to do like ads
and then you put c back in them
and what are the range of operations or
is that is that two broader question
what are the fundamental the fundamental
operations apparently are authentic
i've done this like the number of
operations that a computer does like the
construction sets can have a hundred or
five hundred or a thousand different
instructions
but the most common ones are load data
from memory to the processor
or the program ones
store memory backed those are your first
two instructions
and then add subtract multiply divide
you know clear
you know very simple
it's written
you know then there's what's called
logical operators and or not it's
stunning to me conceptually thinking
through this that
computers which can produce whole worlds
in some sense can
do that as a consequence of
zeros and ones and
arithmetic operators
sure well your brain's
it's doing something interesting like
that there's no magic to it so the the
key to programs is abstraction layers
right so
so at some low level you know like i
understand computers from atoms up to
operators
which is you know fairly broad range but
there's lots of people who can do that
yet i understand them like the surface
of the keyboard
yes
yes monkey with with military helicopter
basically pete bannon had a interview
question so you know computer scientists
would say tell me what happens when i
move when i type a key
right
because you can you can talk all day i
could talk all day then
you know because the key is that the
position which encoded the number which
got sent into the memory there's an
interrupt delivered to a processor to
say there's new data remember to go take
a look at it
but you can describe that in many many
levels
right
so it's it's a good place to start
people it's not bad
alright an interview question it was an
interview yeah right some people by the
way are stumped they go to college and
they can't tell you what happens you
know the key is clicked which is weird
so
so back to the computer so yep with the
basic operations that subtract multiply
divide
you know clear
set the one and or not xor
you know you can take a number and you
can shift it around you can mask it
and so different architectures how are
those operators discovered jim i mean i
know there's their arithmetic operators
and is that just the question of how was
their arithmetic discovered but
i mean
after
way after uh mass
so computers you know at some level
they're doing um arithmetic like it's
not very sophisticated and i'll get to a
little more complicated version of this
and by the time we invented computers
people had pretty good idea of number
theory they'd figured out that base 10
was just one of the bases you could have
two three four five six seven eight
um people had the philosophers had
worked out what logic is
you know if this is true and this is
true then this is true this is true or
this is true
like the logical operators are real
like there's a whole bunch there was a
whole bunch of yeah it's the real it's
the realism of them that's stuck that's
stunning to me yes
so
there's the basic operator set and then
there's something called control flow
so computers typically they put a
program like add you know a equal b plus
c
you know d equals e plus f
f equals e plus a you know
and you typically put that in what's
called
program memory but it's just part of the
memory of the computer
and you have a program counter
which you know i know what's called
counter but the thing that points at the
next instruction to execute and it's
default thing is
do this instruction and then do the one
right after it that became like the the
way computers are built it's an
arbitrary choice by the way you can have
every instruction tell you where to get
the next instruction here's a bunch of
things you can do but for simplicity
people said
this piece of memory has programs in it
start at the first instruction and then
do the next one and the next one next
the program counters
but but that's not good enough because
then you would just start the first one
and you go to the end of memory and be
done
so there's something called control flow
so a program called sorry called control
control
so imagine you wanted to add up a list
of ten numbers so you so your first
instruction says
i'm on the first instruction then you
say
that the sum equals the current sum plus
the next number
increment the counter of how many
instructions i had increment
count by one
and then test
is the counter equal to 10
if yes keep going straight
if no go back to get the next number
right so you created a little loop
right
so and there's it turns out the computer
scientists and invite invented a whole
bunch of kind of loop what they call
control flow constraints
do this while x is true
do this until the counter gets to a
number
right so there's
so you can create little
you know basically sub programs in the
program
right and then there's a couple you can
you can test
like
hey i need to decide if this is a dog or
account so if it's a one go look it here
if it's a zero go look at that
right so that's a conditional branch
with group branches
and then somebody famously invented
subroutines you notice as he was writing
the program
he write he'd write this a little
routine but it would be used a bunch of
different times
so rather than putting the code in
multiple times
it was like define a word and then
whenever i need to use the word i don't
have to put the whole definition for the
word i just put the word
so subroutine is like a local definition
of something or a
local computation that's used multiple
times
your top-level program might be
go to the subroutine that counts up
numbers sums up numbers and come back
now go to the subroutine that checks
whether it's your bank balance or not
come back
so so the program this becomes
sequential operation
control flow like doing loops let's say
do this until something's done
and then conditional branches it says
depending on value do this or that
and then subroutines to do something
atomic and that's essentially all a
program
operations
loops
conditional branches and subroutines
that's it
[Music]
now
why can computers construct worlds
so i i still remember when
so if you look at your screen you know
your the computer in front of you
probably has you know two or four
million pixels on it so it seems like a
lot
right and when they first started you
know televisions when they lit up
screens you know they were scanning the
little electron microscope you know
electron beam across a
phosphorescent surface and lighting and
modulating the intensity of the the
electron gun
to make the little phosphorus brighter
little right and it was writing it
writes one line that it wrote one line
at a time at an incredibly fast rate by
human standards and we saw that as
continual
right yeah
continued the phosphor was designed to
decay at the rate so by the time you
came back to it it just got a little
dimmer and then you wrote it with the
next value so it didn't flicker
so your eye has some persistence so the
electron hits it makes the phosphorous
light up with some photons of the right
color
and then it slowly decays and you scan
down and it gets back there and writes
it again before it's too dim
and so the the screen on a phosphor uh
based television
is it analogous it's an analogous in
some sense but to the binary
representation
that's entirely analog so it's it's it's
digitized in the sense it's discrete i'd
say in the sense that each little pixel
you can see the little fosters in the
screen right especially notice that when
they went to color tvs because they have
a red green and blue thing in there
right right they would hit them
and they they're either they're
essentially either on or off
well they have a range so that that that
beam is a variable intensity
right so no modern computers work
differently so the screen in front of
you
has a little it literally has an xy grid
and it can address each one of those
things
right so you you know you don't shoot a
beam at it anymore you have an xy decode
you know it's almost like the screen
looks like a big flat memory but instead
of storing ones and zeros it's stored in
color
but they have the same kind of decay
property and you write the new color
there's a bunch of stuff now here's the
wild thing
computers are now so fast you can run a
10 000 line program for every single
pixel
on that screen
so what and what does that imply
well
it turns out for a whole bunch of
reasons
like if you want to make something look
really good on the screen
so so the world is relatively continuous
right so if you look at it there's all
this light reflecting around there's all
these things going on there's no little
pixels in the surface of your table
right to make a discrete grid look that
way
you have to you know combine the colors
of you have to do a whole bunch of stuff
you have to pretend you're shining
lights on it you have to you know like
there's a reflection from one surface to
the next one and it turns out when you
have thousands of instructions per pixel
you can start to make those pixels look
realistic
right the operations if you go look in
the pixel program like it looks so
beautiful you think that's incredible
but if you look in the pixel program
it's load the data into the register
add it to a number test it against the
number subtract something
there's something called clipping like
make sure the the pixel doesn't get
brighter than this and dimmer than that
it's all simple operations like there's
nothing in the computer that's like
do a
you know
pixel operation
right well there may be a subroutine
named app but underneath it it's just
the same old stuff
computers always do load store
add subtract multiply divide
branch
and so so did we okay so how far have we
got i'm i'm
listening to so many things i'm having a
hard time keeping track of the order you
you mentioned earlier that compu
computers consist of four elements i
believe that's what you said memory yep
input and output yeah and compute
okay three so i was counting input note
put it separately but okay and have we
gone through all three of them
okay so memory is just the place to
store bits yep input and output is
typically a way to
you know depends on what you're doing
you might just send bits from one place
to another but it might also be you
could say input you know input output in
the computer and sensors are slightly
different things
like sensors you know turn analog world
real world signals into
into digital right and then programs
basically transform the data in some way
and programs is basically
seek you know operations like add
subtract divide
and then branches that we either let you
build loops or make decisions
and then
the hardware that lets you do
subroutines to break the program into
pieces
and that's pretty much it
so to some degree you take the world you
transform it into on off or yes no
billions of those
and then you manipulate the yeses and
no's or the zeros and ones and that can
produce almost any sort of phenomenon
that you can imagine yeah yes or no it's
not a very good you know ones and zeros
is better because then yeah it's a it's
a mathematical representation you know
a digital representation of an analog
reality
something like that
and is the analog reality analog all the
way down or is it digital at the bottom
it's quantum at the bottom
so there's something called defined
constant which makes the universe look
discrete but it's a very very small
number
right
so and there's a fun fact which is
is that the planck length is that
associated with the plank length yeah
and that's the smallest possible length
i believe
like the mass of the universe is 10 to
the 40th and the then the planck length
is 10 to the minus 40.
and there's a there's a
physics thread about the mystery of why
those things are
10 to the 40s and 10 to the 40s
all right so let's move from that to to
um
i'm going to ask you these are the
questions i just want to say so
the thing that makes computers do what
they do is abstraction layers
so
so at the bottom there's atoms so
there's engineers who know how to put
atoms together in a way that makes
switches which we call transistors
right so and those guys are expert at
that stuff right and they just they can
operate at that level
then there's another thing where you
take multiple transistors together and
you basically make what's called logic
gates which literally do the ands and
ors and inversions right
and then
that's an abstraction layer we call it
you know the physical design library or
something like that and then people take
those and they make them up into adders
and subtractors and multipliers this is
a well understood boolean mass so how do
you how do you add two binary numbers
so you make those and then there's
another abstraction layer that says are
i'm going to take multiple
operation units and put them together
to make you know part of the computer
right
and then you make there's a bunch of
those blocks and then that thing runs a
program very simply
and there's small number of people who
write programs at the low level but then
there's people who use what's called
libraries where they you know they're
they're doing some higher level
programming so they're going to do a
matrix multiply and do this map but they
don't actually write that low level code
so there's you know there's a stack of
abstractions
and and when something gets too
complicated
you split the abstraction layer into two
things
it used to be when when people
wrote a program there's a program called
a compiler that translated your c
program or floor training program into
the the low level instructions
but it turns out there's too many
languages up here there's too many
instructions here so now they translated
from the high level language into an
intermediate representation which is
sort of let's say a generic program and
then there's another thing that
translates to immediate representation
that the specific computer you have
but that just keeps going higher and
higher
like a lot of programmers they they use
you know
frameworks that can do amazing things
like you could literally layer a program
that says search the internet for a
picture of a cat sort by color output to
my printer
like just a language or that's a program
search the internet holy cow that runs a
trillion lines of code on a hundred
thousand computers
find a cat that's a really expensive
that's a really complicated program so
how much of the radical increase in
computation power is a consequence of
hardware transformation and how much of
it is a consequence of the the the
increasing density let's say of these
abstraction layers
well so this is this is where you know
there's a really creative tension or
dynamic interplay so when computers
first started they were so slow you ran
really simple programs a equal b plus c
times d
right
and we've been going up the math
hierarchy so then you could run a
program that did what's called you know
matrix math like or linear algebra
systems of big equations and then
matrices and then more complicated ones
so as the computational power went up
you could dedicate more and more
stuff to you know that kind of
computation
and then similar thing happened on
abstraction layers like it used to be
if you bought a million dollar computer
you hand wrote every line of code
because
you didn't want to waste time on the
computer with like overhead
but today you know that million dollar
computer cost 10 cents
you don't really care how many cycles
you use you know parsing a cat video or
something
and so the computation
capacity
let the abstractions at the programming
level increase a lot
so
some of you may have had a graph about
how many bytes does it take to store the
letter a
like
it used to be one
and then word for windows it's like 10
kilobytes per letter
because the letter has a font it has a
color has a shadow
you know there's a whole bunch of you
know and that's fine like you know for
the computer with a million dollars for
you know 100 1 000 bytes of memory you
wouldn't store letter a like that you'd
put it in one byte
but now you have gigabytes and terabytes
of storage who cares
you probably already know that there are
data brokers out there selling your
internet data off to companies who want
to serve you a targeted ad but you might
be surprised to learn that they're also
selling your information to the
department of homeland security and the
irs mask your digital footprint and
protect yourself with expressvpn one of
the easiest ways for brokers to
aggregate data and tie it back to you is
through your device's unique ip address
but when you're connected to expressvpn
your ip address is hidden making it much
more difficult for data brokers to
identify you expressvpn also encrypts
100 of network traffic to keep your data
safe from hackers on public wi-fi you
can download expressvpn on all your
devices your phone your computer even
your home wifi router just tap one
button and you're protected make sure
your online activity and data is
protected with the best vpn money can
buy visit
expressvpn.com
jordan right now and get three extra
months free that's expressvpn.com
jordan
okay so you walk us through the the
basics of computation now can can you
shed some light on
like i i don't understand what you do as
a computer architect like when you when
you go to work when you're working on a
project
what is it that you're actually involved
in doing make ads go faster
so i'm
i'm a fairly low level
engineer
you know low level in terms of the
abstraction leaders like i understand
the higher
but you know i talk to the people who
make transistors and and gates and or
gates
and they talk to the people who know the
atoms
right so so and i hardly ever talk to
the atom people but i know something
about atoms
so i i build uh or arc you know when i
when i'm architecting stuff
um
the
the functional units and then how they
operate together at the low level that
runs programs but i don't write programs
i i build i'm an architect of the
computer that runs programs
right and then
it used to be you could look at a
computer
and you know how to program work you run
the first line the second line if
there's a branch the branch unit and
then you branch
right and the computer would literally
have that in it such an instruction
load the data
do the
operation if there's a branch execute
the branch
if necessary change the program counter
so you know people you know there was a
period of time where computers had like
five stages and each one of them you
could say that's the branch that's the
infection that that's the load unit
that's the ad unit that's the branch
right but monitoring computers are more
complicated than this
right because computers like that would
do one instruction every five cycles
and modern computers the fastest one i
know about
just doing 10 instructions 10
instructions the cycle in parallel
right and this is difficult so the
the best way to unpack that unpack that
so if you write a program since you
write
right when you write you write linear
narrative
right you write a sentence that makes
sense
followed by another sentence
right and so as you're writing along
sometimes the one sentence defines the
meaning of the next sentence right
and then group it into paragraphs
you might call those subroutines right
and sometimes the paragraphs
have to be ordered and sometimes the
paragraph the order doesn't matter that
much
right so programs are written by human
beings and they're written in the same
linear narrative
so if you want to go faster than parsing
the instructions one at a time in order
you have to do some analysis to say all
right i got two sentences
are they dependent or not
if they're dependent i do them in order
if they're not dependent i can do them
in parallel or any order
right and you start so so the modern
computers when they're reading the
programs out
they're
analyzing the dependencies and deciding
what can happen in order what has to
happen in order for practice
correct understanding
and what can be rewarded
and then it turns out there's many
places where you say
if there's an error go here but there's
hardly ever an error you can predict
that really well
so you say
i'm going you're reading along
and you say here's a point where
i'm not sure which should i read the
next sentence or should i jump to the
next paragraph
right so a modern computer predicts that
it doesn't wait for you to fully
understand
all the sentences up to that point so
you know exactly where to read to
but imagine so now you're you're reading
this book
and you're reading sentences in
dependency order
which means you haven't so you get to a
branch and you haven't read all the
sentences before that and understood
them so you don't know where to read the
next paragraph for the next chapter
but we predict what's going to happen
and we just keep on going
and how does that tie into the process
of designing the
so the goal the goal of modern computers
is to go fast well
let me say there's three kinds of
computers
there's computers that
run very simple programs in order
right
they just do exactly what you told them
to do and they tend to be small and
simple
but they're so small and simple you can
make a chip with a thousand of those
computers on
so when you build a gpu that does a
little program for every pixel on your
screen
each one of those pixels gets its own
program it's very simple
but you sort of say the first thousand
pixels you run on these thousand
computers
so like a modern gpu has like currently
like six or eight thousand processors in
it
and they literally
you do the you know the first six
thousand pixels and then the next six
thousand pixels and the next six
thousand pixels and they do that fast
enough that you can run a fairly big
program on every pixel on the screen for
every every screen refreshed on
so you have simple computers that do
stuff in order
right and then you have
let's say computers that are they're
designed to run complicated long
programs as fast as possible
right and that's where you parse the
instructions carefully and you figure
out what order you can do them in and
when possible you reorder
it right and the reason you reorder it
is because if this doesn't depend on
this i can do in parallel now and do two
things at a time the next thing i can
predict that i i can do it in parallel i
can do three things
and you know like i said
the the computer in your desktop is
probably doing three to five things at a
time and the best i know of is ten
right and that's because
and there's other sophisticated
predictors in there so to do that you
have to fetch large groups of
instructions at the time you have to
figure out where the
like the sentence boundaries are
figure out they're dependent or not
figure out
if you can predict where the next
instructions are coming from when you
hit branches
and
it turns out that's fairly complicated
the difference between a little computer
that does
let's say one instruction at a time and
a complicated one that does 10
instructions
it's 100 times more complicated
right and from a
what's the best way to do lots of
instructions complicated computers are
not efficient
but there's so many applications where
people care how fast it is
so when you're like clicking on your web
page
you want that to come up as fast as
possible
so the part of it is that's let's say
what's it called
you know the logic of the of the webpage
it's probably a serial narrative written
by a human being
so you have to you run that on a
complicated computer that you know does
it out of order and predicts what to do
as fast as possible
but when you render the screen itself
that runs on large numbers of simple
computers to make all the pixels
right and then there's the third kind of
computer which
we're starting to invent which is uh ai
computers and that's what you're working
on now
for tens torrent yeah
and there's a there's a really good talk
by andre carpathi
um called software 2.0
so the first two kinds of computers
simple computers and complex out of
order computers they're writing pro
running programs written by humans
right and if you look at the code
it's it's literally a declarative
statements about operations and where to
go
and it's serial it's a linear narrative
yeah the different thing about ai
computers is
you use data to trend
to train the weights and neural networks
to to get you the desired result
so instead of the programs are no longer
written by humans
now
it turns out there's components of the
ai stack that are written by humans
but at a high level you use data
to train them
so you have a big neural network and you
want to detect cats
so you put a cat picture into the
network when you start training and the
output is gibberish
and you compare gibberish to what a cat
is
and you calculate the difference in what
the network said versus the desired
result which is the word cat
and then they do something called back
propagation which is mathematically
sophisticated but essentially take the
error and partition it across the layers
of the network
such that you've sort of bumped each
neuron a little closer to saying cat
next time
by taking the bigger at the end
distributing it across it's called back
propagation
and then you put another cat in
and if you have the right size network
and the right training methods
after you show that network a million
cats when you put a cat in it reliably
says cat and when you put a picture
that's not a cat it reliably says not a
cat
right
and you never wrote any code
that has had anything to do with cats
and can you understand
what it is that the computer is doing
now that it's recognizing cats a little
bit so
people for years worked on visual
computing and they were trying to detect
things like cats
right and cats have a whole bunch of
artifacts they have round eyes they have
pointy ears they have fluffy hair
so you could detect see it's called
feature detection you would say this
will be a cat if i see the following
colors the following amount of
fluffiness the following number you know
two pointy years not three
one or two round eyes depending on the
view
right
so you could write code and the problem
with that is well now the cat has an
arbitrary orientation so you have to you
do your feature detect on the picture
and the features have to search the
whole image and they have to rotate
around
you know and this sort of and and every
single thing you want to detect you have
to write a unique program for you're
done with cats now you go to dogs
and then what about the dog that has
slightly pointy ears those dogs have
round ears and cats have pointy ears
you know so so it was sort of endless
thing right right same thing with
endless endless detail by detail
construction yeah i got a friend who
worked on speech recognition years ago
so you break speech into
you know the the phonemes so you can see
those and then they have frequency
characteristics
and you can differentiate vowels from
consonants so those people working on
speech we're doing a whole bunch of
analysis of analog waveforms of sound
and and they were making some progress
but it never really worked
and then they trained neural networks by
you put the word the word in
and you have
it's called supervised learning so you
play at
language where you know what all the
words are and you keep telling the
network how to correct
and with like a billion samples in a big
enough neural network
it can recognize speech just fine
and if you train it with a broad variety
of accents you can it's it's it can work
across accidents
and then it turns out
the bigger they made these networks the
more information they can put it
and then on the on the cat one
specifically they found
so when they first they first you know
had a neural network crack the cat
problem
um i forget it was like 50 layers deep
and if you looked in the layers you
could see that it was detecting pointy
ears and eyes but it was also protecting
a lot of other things
and some things we don't know yeah well
if we see the back end of the cat
walking away we still know it's a cat
and it pretty much lacks eyes and pointy
ears
from that perspective anything if you
take an object
like in light
right you take a phone you can project
the phone onto a flat surface
say that's a projection
right and as you move it around you get
there's a shadow shadow
but think of it as a projection
right so that's
a projection of a light source on a flat
plane it's a fairly simple projection
but what if you had a light shaped like
a cat and you shined that on the phone
what would the projection look like
and it turns out mathematically
there's an arbitrary number of
projections
you can like we think of projections in
three dimensions because we're
three-dimensional creatures
right but there can be lots of
projections
and then you can have the projection
project on another
plane
so what the neural networks are doing is
they're cheesing out
all the details of what that is
and some of the projection planes give
you what's called you know size and
variance or rotation variance like you
could recognize a cat number which it's
pointing
like your brain is a little specialized
like like faces right it likes to be
very right
yeah but with a little bit of work you
can you can
you can recognize an upside down base
pretty well unless you have a problem
okay so we could do two things here we
could either talk about
your let no let's let's let's go into
your you you were an engineer and then
you were a manager and you've worked in
lots of companies some of which were
incredibly creative some of which were
thriving to an incredible degree and
some of which were collapsing and and
and irreparable
so
what have you learned about what makes
companies work and more importantly what
have you learned about
what makes them not work
and maybe
what do you do then
sure well that's a fun question um
well first of all there's like i've
noticed that many people have noticed
this is not just me that people gen like
in engineering fields people
kind of bucket towards you know
technical people and management people
and and it's not that there aren't good
technical managers or there's not good
managers or technical people can manage
right
right but that's an intersection of two
skills say yeah but generally speaking
most people are one with you
and it's like when you wake up in the
morning or you want to solve a problem
or do you want to organize the problem
like you are you worried about your
schedule your head counts and
how things are getting done and did you
hit the milestones
or are you working on technical problems
and people and then in engineering
fields it's often there's the fellow
track to the technical leadership
position or the director of ep track the
management leadership
right so i'm a technical person
but you took on management rules
repeatedly well i did because
i found out that if you're generally
speaking the top of the organization is
the manager the vp
and as a technical person no matter how
how high you go your advisor to that
person
and i decided consciously after i worked
at apple
that i was going to be a vp and have
everybody work for me because then i can
make it
right so then
my skill set is somewhat unusual and i'm
not the only one obviously
but i decided to
you know get on the management track
so i could build the computers i wanted
because sometimes
when i wasn't the leader of the group
some managers at some point would decide
they own the next decision and they
would make some random decisions
i'd be grumpy about it and there's
nothing i could do about it because they
did people work for them not for me so
so that's you know it was a conscious
thing and i hired a consultant ben
catrao
who helped me reframe how i approached
this
now i'm still a technical person but i
found that
turns out there's a whole bunch of
really good technical managers that i
like to work with i'd like to organize
stuff
and i would say you know i maintain my
openness and low conscientiousness
and disagreeable behavior and i have
people work for me
work on my team or work with people that
man's better
so
so even though i've been a manager you
know amd was 2400 people total at the
end and until it was 10 000.
my staff is you know 15 or 20 people
and usually half of them are
real managers and half of them are
technical leaders
that's how we solve it and
and there's lots of companies running
away a lot of times founders tend to be
technical people but people working for
them are not
or or they're stronger on the management
side than the technical side
um but for everybody you need to decide
who you are
like i had a great technical manager at
amd in one day he was he's a little mess
because i was looking to the you know a
couple of really technical heavyweights
to solve a problem he said he said you
know i'm pretty technical i said yeah i
know
i said are you are you technical
compared to jim and the barb and
he goes i guess not really he said i
know i really like you know
what i want you to do is you're running
this project you have 150 people working
for you
you make all the technical decisions you
can but when it's it's out of your
wheelhouse we got serious experts
and you have two choices you can call
them or i can call them
and he later told me he said i found
that it was a lot better when i called
him than when you called him
and
successful thing and he was technical he
was really good at making good decisions
but he wasn't the strongest technical
person in the group
so
that's the first thing is you know
figure out who you are i've seen a lot
of people fail in engineering because at
some point they think
i'm technical but i want to get on the
management track but they're bored by
management
and they don't have a plan to deal with
it and so yeah well you weren't bored by
management and and so so i joke that i i
decided to see the organization the
computer architecture problem
and treat me well that's exactly what i
was going to ask what transformation did
you have to undertake to so one of them
was
what do i have to do to be effective
right so that's you know i hate to work
on failed projects
right and then the next was
the organizational problem it's itself
is an architectural problem
and then i kept
you know for myself well i'm a funny
kind of if some something has a solution
and it's being confidently driven i'm
not that interested i like problems
and
so in a big organization there's a
million problems and i start sorting
them by priority and then solving some
of them or handing them out to the right
people
so there's a whole bunch of technical
work to do on that
and then i'm fairly good at skill
assessing people
who are technical
either for management or technical
positions
and then
you know giving them work and like i
like i'm
i like autonomy and management
so if somebody's competent they can do
it they understand it
um
ben gave me a bunch of books to read and
one of the frameworks
is uh goals organization contract and
teamwork
or capabilities i guess we usually solve
for that so is the goal super clear
do we have the capability to solve the
problem is there a contract between me
and the groups doing it so they know
what to do you know what what their
goals you know boxer in
right and do they have the you know the
um is the organization that
like a lot of times there's a joke that
startups start with a problem and build
organizations support it but on the
second third system the organization
defines the problem
rather than the problem defined in the
organization and then it breaks up
yeah then the organization becomes the
problem yes
yeah they constrain the problem and
become the problem
well we had a number of discussions
while you were doing this about ethics
and i mean you said that you go you look
at the problems well that's hard right
because you have to know enough to know
what the problems are then you have to
be willing to look at the problems well
then you prioritize them like you you
skipped over that very quickly but all
of that's extraordinarily difficult i
would say both cognitively and
emotionally
sometimes it isn't sometimes it isn't
like when i joined the amp the cpus were
less than half as fast as the
competition
and they had no plan to catch up so that
that wasn't that hard no but what would
be hard there i would presume is
figuring out how it could be that
such an obvious problem had gone
undetected and unsolved
and then
no actually one of their architects when
i was working at apple told me that they
believed that cpu performance had
plateaued it wasn't going to get any
faster and they were going to work on
adding features to the rest of the chip
and then intel came in and said we think
computers are going to get five or ten
percent faster every year and they did
it
one had one goal which is you know
things slow down the other had a
different goal five or ten percent isn't
a lot
but you do that ten years in a row
and you know the other guys weren't so
that wasn't that complicated
like elon famously said he tells
everybody secret plans and nobody
believes and then doesn't and they still
don't believe them and then they're like
oh
so intel publicly said they were going
five or ten percent faster every year
and named he said no they're not
you know
and
the results were at some point that the
gap got bigger and bigger and you know
the people in amd were committed to
their plan
i don't know
why it's interesting how these things
get internalized and then you start
even when they you know at some point
you know how it is it's cognitive
dissonance you say you're going to do
something different but you've learned
how to do this other thing really well
you keep doing it
right and then
well you'll be able to hold machinery
around it yes exactly you know they had
a big machine that did all kinds of
stuff that was perfectly useful
right and good people doing it like like
i said we didn't hire any people to
build them
but we did refactor you know you know
reset the goals refactor a whole bunch
of
engineering okay so well at amd you were
successful twice
and so and
the success was both building a chip
that was competitive so you had to put
together the teams to build the chip but
also to transform the internal structure
of the company so that that became
possible and then also to communicate
that to your to your customers and so
what's the problem set up there i didn't
communicate to the customers i
you know
because you know computer we're all
performance cells
okay so that's the first thing you
brought to the table performance cells
and here we're going to break that down
here's the measurements here's the mesh
and there's lots of public benchmarks
like everybody tries to gain it but
generally speaking there's a really big
community of computer users and they
know what they want and they know what's
fast right and you know exactly how a
computer works so you can actually say
once you decide that what faster is
better
that does that work on on all of the
elements of design
i mean there's
like you could make it faster nobody
would care like yeah there's some
judgment calls in it but it's not that
complicated
like you know today on phones there's a
thing called geekbench and you know you
get a number at the end you know is your
geekbench score 100 or 50 hundreds
better
right right right the people who made
the benchmark tried to pick the
components of your phone experience such
that the geekbench number represented
whether the phone was faster or not
and then whether you care that's another
question like for the current
applications that they got twice as fast
you might not notice but as the computer
gets faster so new applications are
possible
and on the phone where it's possible
it's great where it's not possible it
feels slow and laggy
right so
so performance wins and you know
different form factors like a notebook
or a desktop or a phone have different
amounts of power
to live within the budget okay so so you
had a goal you had the measurements in
place you decompose that into tasks you
assign competent people what what
psychological factors got in the way
like how did you seek all of these
yeah fair enough all of them but what
what did you see specifically interfe
once you have a good plan in place that
doesn't necessarily mean it's going to
be implemented and so what are the
mistakes that people make
that you saw in large companies that
doom the company so that stop them from
transforming internally and
so so
so there's a couple very separate
problems when
when somebody with a good set of ideas
says i need to transform this place
like
there's there's are the goals proper
right
and then you want to say do i have the
capability in the team to do it do i
like i worried when i went to amd i
wouldn't have enough experts in certain
things to do it i'd have to hire 50
people to fix it but it turns out there
was i did
plenty of
you know there was plenty of good people
actually some really great people
so i was like you know pretty quickly
checked off the capability box and then
you start wondering well why the hell
are we doing the right thing well the
problem was the goals were wrong and
then the organization was wrong
right and then generally speaking if
those aren't right so to begin so maybe
to begin with the goals weren't
unreasonable
and no one knew but then across time the
fact that one set of goals was better
than the other the belief that computers
weren't going to get much faster was a
bad goal in the world where the
competitor believed they were going to
get a lot faster
yes and could do it and that became
incrementally worse across time to the
point where it became cataclysmic yeah
so
so you got to get the goals right and
you got to establish whether you have
capabilities you know those are the kind
of fundamentals but then the
organization building is hard
because somebody will tell you so-and-so
is a great manager
well is he
all right or you know like a lot of
times there's somebody that looks like a
good manager but you just have three
people working for us it's really good
the problem with that is when things are
going well
the the empty suit manager
with his good people supporting him
make things look like they're making
lots of progress but when they run into
hard problems and the technical guys
know what to do they go to him and makes
a random decision or does something dumb
or doesn't believe them like that
happens a lot like technical guy goes to
the empty suit manager and says
you know i i think this isn't working we
need to change and you know he says
now we're fine we just look right way
through it right so
so you get these weaknesses in the
organization because you don't have
skill level like i said
i work with a lot of really good
technical managers
who know when they can make the decision
and they know when they have to punt to
somebody who's more of an expert
that's great and it turns out some
people are so good at that they can
operate way higher than you think
because they're not technically strong
you're super good
at translating and making judgment calls
like that
so you gotta start look building your
organization
and then there's stuff about how do you
build teams like some groups are what
you call functional but all the people
who do software in one group and all the
people who do hard work all people do
atoms in another group
right and then the managers but if the
thing you're building needs a little of
all three of those things
you know it's
called uh you know
functional organization versus product
organization you might want a team with
a couple of programmers a couple
hardware people a couple adam people
in the same team
so they're all they're all they all have
one goal
as opposed to the functional group says
i'll make them the best software
was it the right thing for this product
they go i don't know it don't work on
the product i work on software so i'm
generally speaking you know product
focus
so i organized so if you only have like
five of some some discipline
you you tend to make a little functional
team like that there's a couple things
in computer design which are functional
but generally speaking i like i like
product focus organization
so everybody's like they're all working
together on the same thing they may have
different disciplines
um
though
amd now you've encountered all sorts of
all sorts of frustrations
sorry you've encountered all sorts of
frustrating situations when you've gone
into companies that
where you're trying to put together a
good product and so what what have you
what have you seen what do you see as
particularly counterproductive and what
have you learned like how to conduct
yourself so that you can be successful
weak leadership people who can't make
the technical decisions they have to
that's a big problem
functional organizations where people
are optimizing for the function not the
product
bad goals is one of the worst things
um
some some organizations have real
capability gaps
like you know they think they have the
right people but they don't
you know some managers play favorites
they think stone's always really good
and they're not yeah so that's that's a
real functional analysis that the
company just just can't do what it needs
to do
um yeah so so and we're still analyzing
here's the group they're actually from
you know some place there's a goat
there's there's a belief that we're
going to build this product it has to be
a great product and have you how do you
do the
you know basic blocking tactics and how
to make that successful
right that's different than the malay
and the malaise that overtakes big
success companies
which you can generically call
bureaucratic capture
right that's a different
different problem like a company that's
bureaucratically
captured
will manifest all kinds of bad behavior
in the organization and product
development but
and then
you know some some big companies where
the you know the
the bureaucracy has taken over there
might still be groups that are really
doing a great job making great products
you know so there's you know i think
there are separate spaces and i
understand both of them pretty well
and again you know the way it's all big
complicated problems you have some
abstractions about what you're dealing
with
so you know a framework like goals
organization capability contract is is a
super clear method for evaluating what
the hell is going on and then making
changes
you know very specific changes to it
cults are clear you know if you're not
clear nothing else matters get the goals
clear
right capabilities are they good
you don't direct capabilities nothing
will save you you have to have the
ability to do the job you're doing
you know the organizations serve the
goals
that's a big problem that's painful one
that's because that's when you start
changing who works for who and what the
boundaries are and
but but you have to you have to do it
okay so let's let's tackle it this way
then so
you're going to pick someone who has
optimal attributes to
to uh
uh what would create and operate within
a highly functional organization what
are you looking for in that person
what's what's crucial
well
people are fairly diverse that's you
know that's the funny thing
so engineers need to have this will to
create if they're technical leaders okay
and then they have to have the
discernment to make no decisions about
whether they're actually making progress
towards the goals or just wasting their
time on something cute
right that's that's the thing
uh technical managers you know
they need to know how to run a program
they need to how to hire and fire they
need to how to structure work they need
to know how to evaluate how long it's
going to take
how to evaluate whether people are
making progress
there's a whole bunch of things but then
people have very different styles some
people are very extroverted i worked
with this woman she was great she would
just have these team meetings and she
would really get out there and energize
the team
and another guy in the same building was
very low-key and he would wander around
and talk to people and have a really
good sense of the team like a like an
introvert versus extrovert style
but they both worked they were both very
competent and they were both
to me
you know
really good technical competency they
weren't my technical leads but they were
technically competent enough
to make the decisions and know when they
had to
punt the decision up
so who do you not want who do you not
okay so i mean that kind of goes along
with the management literature you see
that you want people who are intelligent
especially for complex jobs so they can
learn you want people who are
conscientious because they work hard and
they have integrity
then with the other dimensions it looks
like there's a fair bit of variability
although
too much negative emotionality can be a
problem i think that's because it's
associated with depression and too much
anxiety and so on but there's diversity
in the other personality dimensions and
that might be task specific but what do
you what's what what sort of person do
you not want to work with
fakes
there's lots of fakers out there
you know you know they have sales
attributes they're you know extroverted
agreeable
you know they they want to say
everything is good all the time they're
not sufficiently
concerned about disaster and digging
into stuff they may have some kind of
narcissistic personality problem
so there's so they're imposters they're
they're mimicking competence they're
making confidence that's a problem there
are people who literally take credit
from other people yeah well i i kind of
put that in a separate boat but there's
people who don't gain credit for their
team their teams you know
you know like i i realize early on
there's two kinds of managers whose
people get up and people shut down like
like as a marriage i i often tangle with
the people i work for
but i always took care of the people
work for me
but some other man you know i had this
one guy looked at me i thought he was
great and then i i walked by a meaning
he was having he was
abusing this team and they hated him
i fired him because he he always said
the nice things to me and
you know he get on those people
so it's
yeah there's there's a bunch of weird
stuff that happens with management like
that like you have to be excited like if
you're a senior manager in high tech
thing there's many people in the group
that are smarter than you and you have
to promote them and put that forward you
can't
be
uncomfortable
because somebody's smart you know
when i was in amd i had six senior
fellows i think they were all smart
they weren't
they weren't as generalists or something
you know and they weren't didn't have my
interest in you know architecture
organization
but man was smart super good
i could talk to them all you know i
could keep up with them more for
sometimes
but you know i was more than happy to
promote them as the smart guys like
why why were you confident enough do you
think to allow
your you to be surrounded by people that
you i experience beautiful equipment
like i'm above average smart but i i met
people who are so smart like i i knew
butler lampson was you know famous
unrated iq and his wife was smarter it
was a joke that he spoke at half lampson
because his wife was smart and smoked
spoke really fast
but i at a fairly young age i was
confident in getting things done
and work with people that were smarter
than me but they they they liked my
you know i'm an engineer and i built
stuff you know this you know this rocket
scientist they think it up and then they
hope somebody would build it for them
because they're off onto the next thing
so that's you know a belief i have
you know it wasn't always easy
i still remember
i was working on ev5 and i went to the
digital research lab and there's half of
those super smart people
and i started describing what i was
doing and i would describe something for
about two minutes and then they would
spend five minutes taking it apart and
analyzing how it could be like way
better and then they'd ask me the next
question and after an hour of that i
felt like oh my god it was just beating
to death
and uh they were like this is great jim
i was like you thought that was great
they're like yeah we're glad you're
doing it
so
i've always had that attitude since
you know
but yeah it's hard on some people when
they realize how smart some people are
now so what i make up for it because i'm
open-minded and i worked my ass off for
many years and then i dived in lots of
things and then
you know i'm not afraid to ask dumb
questions i i you know
like a lot of people protect they're
trying to project who they are so they
don't ask right questions they don't
learn anything
and i'm like i don't really don't
understand what the hell is going on
i've done that from a room with 50
people and they're like well we thought
you should know it's like well i don't
but i'm not going to leave until i do
and then they give all the information
and then i'm smarter than i used to be
and you know so that that takes a
certain
you know mental resilience and sometimes
it's very hard
[Music]
but you know again it's sort of like
you know do you fire the people you have
to fire
to save the group and save the product
maybe save the company yeah because then
that good is really high
and that's the right thing to do
so exposing yourself is the right thing
to do ironically
now it's hard and it's hard and you know
well if you admit you're stupid then
sometimes you don't have to stay that
way yeah
it's hard in some sick organizations
sometimes it's not safe to expose
yourself
and i feel for people who are in places
where they would really like to be more
open and can't because you know
organizations that political and
bureaucratic
are hard on people that are are actually
trying to do the right thing and learn
so i totally understand that it takes a
while to you know the psychological
safety thing is
it gets overused and gets a bad rap but
having an organization where it's
actually safe to open your mouth and
talk and ask questions and occasionally
look stupid and
you know and fumble a little bit and
have your
your peers like support you with that
and be happy for you when you learn
stuff
like that's really important it's hard
to do
you know and so and there's great
attention because you know as a leader
you have to be disagreeable enough to do
the hard things or still creating an
environment where people can open up and
do that
you know i would say i'm mixed i have
mixed reviews on that topic
because once i feel find things that are
wrong and people are doing the wrong
thing you know
i have to get to the bottom but
and i'm gonna i'm gonna close with some
people it's never happened to them
before
like the people haven't really taken
what apart you know they got a's in
college and they got good reviews
they rose to their peter principle
incompetence point all of a sudden
they're doing something they're over
their head and they know what to do
about them have a lot of practice
so
yeah it's a funny it's a funny thing
so i'm going to close with
uh
a question about your current venture
you're you're you're now working with a
company that does ai computing and
what do you hope
to do
that you can talk about
well so i was an investor in this
company when it first started the visa
project who's the founder
worked with me at amd and i always
thought he was an especially smart guy
and i liked his approach
to building ai computation um
i'm really intrigued about computers
programmed by data
right i think it's more like how our
brains work
our brains are really weird right
because we think in this linear
narrative we have this little voice in
our head but we know we have 10 billion
neurons and they're
collecting away you know exchanging you
know small amounts of brain transmitters
and electrical pulses
you know it's bloody hilarious and gap
between what a neuron looks like and
what a thought looks like
and so
there's a really interesting opportunity
to make big ai computers that are
actually really programmable
so one of the things we're doing is
we're building the software stack that
lets you build the neural networks you
want and then program and get the
results you expect reasonably well
as opposed to having a very large army
of people tweaking it
and
so there's there's a bunch of
architectural interesting things to do
and then it's a startup which
you know we have chips at work we
started production we're going to start
selling them
you know there's a whole bunch of work
to do on how to engage with customers
and a lot of customers we're talking to
are super smart there's all these you
know ai software startups
with really smart people that you know
have some some problems that you know
basically if the computers were a
million times faster it would be easier
to solve so there's like a huge capacity
gap
on what they want to do so participating
that's fun like i like that kind of
thinking
and your goal so you go into an
organization you have a goal for the
chips what's your goal for this
organization
oh we're going to be successful selling
i can do this a large number of people
you know significantly better
performance better better
programmability and lower cost
and there's a bunch of innovation work
to do around that
um to make that really possible doable
like the ai field is relatively new the
computers that run ai today are
relatively clunky
and to me you know need a lot of work
and refinement so that you know from the
the idea that you want to express in the
program you're writing to the result you
want better and cleaner
okay so one final question
for anyone who's listening who would
like to pursue engineering as a career
or let's say who wants to be successful
within the confines of a big company
what what advice do you have
for people
what have you learned that that you can
sum up
yeah alex friedman asked me that um
first you have to you know you have to
know yourself a bunch like what are you
good at like
like you can't get really good at
something you're not into
and you and you're not good at it so you
have to you have to have some natural
talent for it and then you have to
really spend some time figuring out
which which you like
like um
i've read this thing it was interesting
like people think of colleges expanding
their possibilities and the university
itself has so many options you think
that would expand your possibilities but
once you pick one of them then you study
it for four
eight ten years you've narrowed your
possibilities right you're kind of stuck
with your discipline that you picked at
which i think is crazy by the way like i
think if you want to be an engineer a
good general engineering degree like
mechanical engineering or electrical
engineering will give you thinking skill
sets
i'm not a huge fan of people getting
phds unless they really really know they
love it
right and then
take some jobs where
you know there's an opportunity to do
something for a year or two and then do
something else
like i worked
my first job out of school was a random
job
i worked on like five different projects
in two years while i was there you know
fixing hardware building something
debugging something
i learned a lot in the digital i i had
many different roles even though i was
at that company for 15 years
i wrote programs i did logic design i
did testing
i did lab work you know and so
i got to see a lot of different things
and get a feel for what i really liked
and i worked with smart people that you
know
i had a lot to learn from
i'm working hard when you're young is
really useful
you know some people like well
you know it's like the ten thousand hour
problem and if you want to be an expert
you need to do that a couple different
times on different things
and you can't do it unless you really
love it
a friend of mine's wife said what do
they put in the water all you guys do is
talk about work yeah so you figure out
what you're competent at
because you need that figure out what
you're interested in i mean men and
women seem to pick different occupations
not based on their competence but on
their interest
and so interest is a new is a very
powerful motivating factor oh and that
was it i've been in a lot of places with
the best engineers for women so you know
you know we know that numbers are less
but
there's plenty of really great yeah it
certainly doesn't make it impossible
it's just an indication of the of the uh
what would you call it of the impact of
interest as a phenomenon it's important
as well as competence yeah
and and so
a diverse range of experiences yeah
don't don't over index on something
before you're really you know sure that
that's something that you're really
going to like or be great at
you know
don't be don't be afraid to ask stupid
questions if you don't know what you're
doing
yeah
uh try to work with good people
work in organizations where like
if everybody hates the company you're
working in move somewhere else you want
to work work some place where the energy
is good people are excited about what
they're doing and why
like sometimes you might be in a company
that has a
you know something going wrong but your
group is you know going to change it
that's that can be really fun but you
need some camaraderie some you know hope
right when the goal's clear
right so that's an adventure you have
you have a destination and the
camaraderie along the way yeah and
there's
you know there's so many places doing so
many wild things being stuck in a
company you don't like that's going
nowhere for 10 years man
you don't have that many 10 years
swastika life
you know make sure you're actually
getting especially if you're on getting
different experience
somebody said you know you have 10 years
experience or one year of experience 10
times right
no sometimes you work on the same thing
and you refine it you become the expert
but then you should feel like you're
making progress
right
but if you're just kind of going through
the motions over and over and doing it
then it's time to fire yourself under
those conditions you're
you're not moving right like
engineering's not boring right it's
relatively exciting yeah i think that's
actually a pretty good rule of thumb if
you're bored you're doing it wrong yeah
something's wrong yeah it's funny it's
like like like an amd we had this group
that did test and it was it was kind of
dysfunctional there's a couple managers
and nobody liked it
and at some level the test engineering
wasn't the hardest thing
um
so but i decided that's good why isn't
it oh isn't our test group the best in
the world but we were organized around
it we had a really great leader we had a
good team
um i told him i wanted to be really
great and i told the engineers to stop
complaining about it they had a problem
come to me and we'll fix it within two
years people come to me he's like man
the test guys are killing
yeah
yeah they went above and beyond they
they made it something of value
you know it was great it's super fun
that's a really good place to end
well
thanks jim hey good to see you man
much appreciated thank you for taking
the time all right we'll talk soon
cheers bye
you